[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und Marietta Slomka guten Abend in
mehreren Bundesländern gehen an diesem
Wochenende die Herbstferien zu Ende wer
verreist war kehrt in ein Land mit stark
steigenden coronazahlen zurück und
einige werden selbst das Virus aus dem
Urlaub mitbringen das war bisher ja bei
jeder Reisewelle so es ist also kein
schlechter Zeitpunkt für den
weltgesundheitsgipfel der gerade in
Berlin abgehalten wird der World Health
Summit geht auf eine Initiative der
Charité zurück seit seiner Gründung
befasst er sich mit internationalen
Gesundheitsthemen und was könnte
internationaler sein als eine Pandemie
nur dass sie nach wie vor nicht
international bekämpft wird selbst
innerhalb Europas werden von Regierungen
ja sehr unterschiedliche Entscheidungen
getroffen und auch die Bevölkerungen
verhalten sich unterschiedlich
in der Kirsten und Annette hilsenbeck
zeigen das am Beispiel von Lettland und
Italien das Virus ist das gleiche die
Lage in den beiden Ländern aber völlig
unterschiedlich
er ist wieder da der Lockdown in
Lettland seit vier Tagen ist fast alles
dicht Geschäfte Sportstätten es gilt
Homeoffice Pflicht Homeschooling
zwischen 20 und 5 Uhr darf sogar nur
raus wer einen guten Grund hat die
schlechten Zahlen machen das nötig denn
nirgendwo sonst in Europa ist die
Inzidenz höher liegt bei 836,9
natürlich ist es schwierig früher
pulsierte hier das Leben jetzt passiert
gar nichts mehr
bisher waren die Letten ohne so strenge
Einschränkungen durch die Pandemie
gekommen eine Impfung erschien viele
nicht notwendig doch dann stiegen die
Neuinfektionen rapide der Regierung
blieb nur noch die Notbremse
ich muss alle geimpften dazu aufrufen
darauf vorbereitet zu sein diese Last zu
ertragen was unfair ist ich weiß
nur knapp die Hälfte ist geimpft
48,5%. viele sind skeptisch Minderheiten
wie etwa die russische werden von der
Impfkampagne kaum erreicht hinzu kamen
Fehlinformationen mittlerweile gibt es
eine Impfpflicht für den medizinischen
und öffentlichen Bereich
hätten wir vor drei Wochen angefangen
etwas zu tun wäre kein Lockdown oder
eine Ausgangssperre nötig gewesen weil
das verpasst wurde und die lettischen
Krankenhäuser an einem nicht allzu guten
Zustand sind ist der notwendig
die meisten Intensivpatienten sind
ungeimpft das erhöht den Druck mehr
Menschen von einer Impfung zu überzeugen
und so die Zahlen zu senken die
Inzidenzen sind in Europa sehr ungleich
verteilt rot steht für viele Infektionen
grün für wenige das liegt auch an den
Impfquoten aber nicht nur denn nicht
jedes Land mit einer hohen Impfquote je
grün hat automatisch eine geringe
Inzidenz andere Maßnahmen spielen eine
Rolle wie etwa das Beispiel Italien
zeigt
Dolce Vita das süße Leben in Italien ist
es wieder zu spüren die Pandemie scheint
im Griff die Zahl der Corona neu
infizierten seit längerem stabil niedrig
die Inzidenz 33,1
ohne Probleme essen gehen drinnen oder
draußen wo immer ich will ein aperitifo
trinken Bekannte treffen das ist einfach
wunderschön
ein Grund bereits
74,8% der Gesamtbevölkerung sind
vollständig immunisiert lieber sich
impfen lassen das Trauma des vergangenen
Jahres mit vielen corona-opfern hartem
Lockdown will keiner mehr erleben Volk
und Regierung sind sich da selten einig
ich möchte nochmals allen Bürgern danken
die sich haben impfen lassen auch denen
die sich erst in den letzten Wochen dazu
entschieden haben nachdem sie ihre
Bedenken überwunden haben denn das
erlaubt uns Schulen Unternehmen und
andere Orte wo wir uns begegnen offen zu
halten
dazu hat premier Draghi strenge
Maßnahmen verordnet die Kontrolle des
greenpass fast überall sogar am
Arbeitsplatz der belegt dass man geimpft
genesen oder frisch getestet ist
eine Sache des Bewusstseins nicht der
Freiheit an andere zu denken nicht nur
an sich selbst
haben wieder gezeigt wenn du ein Opfer
bringst und in Regeln folgst ist das gut
für alle
so genießen Sie in Italien das Leben
wieder und bleiben doch vorsichtig
derweil bei uns die Zahlen weiter nach
oben schnellen das Robert Koch-Institut
meldet heute
13.732 neue Fälle das sind 5.050 mehr
als vor einer Woche 23 Menschen starben
in Verbindung mit dem Virus die sieben
Tage Inzidenz steigt erstmals wieder
seit Mai auf über 100 nämlich auf 106,3
und darüber wollen wir sprechen mit dem
Bundesgesundheitsminister guten Abend
Herr Spahn schönen guten Abend Frau
Slomka würden sie vor dem Hintergrund
dieser Zahlen sagen dass Corona nach wie
vor eine ernsthafte Gefahr für die
öffentliche Gesundheit ist
Corona ist immer noch eine große
Herausforderung für jeden einzelnen weil
er unser Alltag auch weiterhin bestimmt
ist von Vorsichtsmaßnahmen 3G im
Innenraum Maske in Bus und Bahn
aufeinander acht geben übrigens nicht
nur wegen Corona auch andere
Atemwegserkrankungen werden uns jetzt im
Herbst und Winter beschäftigen und ja es
wird auch für das Gesundheitswesen wie
immer in Herbst und Winter eine
besonders schwierige Zeit werden und
deswegen ist es eben auch wichtig wie
gesagt dass einige Maßnahmen weiterhin
gelten gleichzeitig weil das ja
wahrscheinlich auch Ihre Frage mit
impliziert die epidemische Lage der
Ausnahmezustand vom Bundestag
festgestellt der kann aus meiner Sicht
beendet werden weil vier von fünf
Erwachsene geimpft sind für das
Robert-Koch-Institut ist klar geimpfte
haben ein moderates Risiko und diese
Balance jetzt zu halten vom
Ausnahmezustand in den Zustand
besonderer Vorsicht darum geht's aber
mit Zustand besonderer Vorsicht der ist
bisher gesetzlich nicht definiert
sondern wir haben eben diese epidemische
Lage von nationaler Tragweite und die
hat eine klare gesetzliche Definition
nämlich das von einem Virus in diesem
Fall eine ernsthafte Gefahr für die
öffentliche Gesundheit ausgeht also
warum jetzt ausgerechnet wo die Zahlen
wieder nach oben gehen um das ganz klar
ist dass es ein ordentliche vierte Welle
gibt warum ausgerechnet jetzt quasi die
Epidemie für beendet erklären das ist er
ausdrücklich nicht dass worum es geht
die Pandemie die Epidemie für beendet zu
erklären wir haben festgehalten auch ich
sage beständig wie viele andere auch wir
brauchen den Herbst und Winter weiterhin
Vorsichtsmaßnahmen vor allem 3G geimpft
gewesen getestet im Innenraum vor allem
Maske medizinische Schutzmaske
aha-regeln im Bus und Bahn im
Einzelhandel und unser Ziel ist dass am
Bund und Länder vereinbart mit Hilfe
auch des impffortschrittes mit diesen
beiden Maßnahmen jetzt durch Herbst und
Winter zu kommen übrigens ein drittes
muss noch dazu ein drittes muss übrigens
noch dazu kommen wenn ich das sagen darf
die auffrische Impfungen sind sehr sehr
wichtig ich möchte auch ausdrücklich
werden das vor allem die über
60-Jährigen die auch wahrnehmen die
Bundesländer sind überhaupt nicht
begeistert davon dass Ihnen diese
einheitliche gesetzliche Grundlage für
Maßnahmen weggenommen wird warum
forcieren sie das dann so wenn doch ganz
offensichtlich auch die die da jetzt
durch die nächsten Monate kommen müssen
sie müssen es ja nicht mehr das lieber
beibehalten würden
nun wir haben ja diese Diskussion das
ist ein Paragraf ein Absatz im
Infektionsschutzgesetz auf dem die
Länder die Kommunen ihre Maßnahme
rechtlich Gründen diese Diskussion ja
schon geführt auch im Sommer das ist
durch eine Rechtsänderung möglich dass
das auch losgelöst vom diesem
Ausnahmezustand weiterhin möglich ist
für die Länder für die Behörden vor Ort
die Maßnahmen zu ergreifen das
unterstütze ich auch ausdrücklich und
das ist ja auch das wo wir im Kontakt
sind wo wir beraten und unterstützen
auch die drei Parteien die gerade die
neue Regierung bilden das ist ja eine
besondere Zeit gerade im Übergang von
einer Regierung zur nächsten und auch
dort ist erklärtes Ziel um das auch zu
sagen durch eine Veränderung im Gesetz
den Ländern den Kommunen weiterhin vor
allem 3G und Maske im Bus und Bahn
möglich zu machen
Intensivmediziner sagen es wird schon
wieder langsam kritisch und das ist
jetzt ein völlig falsches Signal der
Bevölkerung zu sagen huhu
Ausnahmezustand beendet
ich finde Frau slomker und das ist
natürlich die Herausforderung wir müssen
ja auf beide schauen wir haben schon
ziemlich viel geschafft wie gesagt vier
von fünf Erwachsene sind geimpft für
geimpfte ist das Risiko deutlich 80%
eigentlich bitte wie kommen sie auf die
80 Prozent nehmen Sie jetzt das
telefonmonitoring oder nehmen Sie die
beim RKI gemeldeten Zahlen das sind die
beim RKI gemeldeten Zahlen
wahrscheinlich werden es noch mehr sein
sie haben ja darauf hingewiesen gerade
ist sind nicht alle nicht jeder einzelne
Impfung bei über 100 Millionen Impfungen
ist tatsächlich gemeldet worden da geht
über neun oder zehn Monate im Alltag
auch mal eine Meldung durch deswegen ist
es wichtig dass wir eben neben den
Meldungen auch die Umfragen haben aber
allein schon die gemeldeten Impfungen
führen dazu dass vier von fünf
Erwachsenen in Deutschland er geimpft
sind das Risiko ist damit auch moderat
wie das RKI sagt für diese Erwachsenen
und das ist erstmal was was Zuversicht
macht dass wir schon ein ganzes Stück
des Weges gegangen sind und jeder von
uns merkt das doch im Alltag also mit
einer Inzidenz von wären wir noch vor
sechs sieben Monaten jetzt in einer ganz
anderen Phase in der ganz anderen
Situation und gleichzeitig dürfen wir im
Moment wieder genauso viel wie Leute wie
im letzten Herbst und diese Zeit hat
sich nicht so viel geändert aber ich
wurde gern auf das Impfen noch mal
zurück tatsächlich liegt die gesamte
Impfquote ja bei ungefähr 67 Prozent
vollständig bezogen auf die ganze
Bevölkerung das ist ja kein Erwachsenen
Virus die Kinder stecken sich genauso an
und tragen es auch weiter also warum
lassen sie die Kinder da außen vor wir
haben 28 Millionen im 25 Millionen
ungeimpfte Menschen hierzulande nein ich
lasse niemand aus dem vollem Gegenteil
ich werde sehr dafür auch bei den
Ländern dass in den Schulen und in den
Pflegeeinrichtungen da wo die besonders
verwundbaren sind die jüngsten und die
ältesten dass dort weiterhin regelmäßig
getestet wird das ist dort besondere
Schutzmaßnahmen gibt das vor allem auch
da eben in den alten Einrichtungen die
Auffrischimpfung jetzt stattfinden das
müssen wir jetzt natürlich weiter tun
und deswegen da bin ich ja bei Ihnen
Frau Slomka ist das jetzt wichtig darauf
hin ist jetzt nicht normal es ist jetzt
nicht so alles wie vorher da sind wir
noch nicht wir sind jetzt in einem
Zustand besonderer Vorsicht wo auch
bestimmte Schutzmaßnahmen weiterhin
gelten und gleichzeitig können wir
jedenfalls den Ausnahmezustand wo der
Bundesminister für Gesundheit etwa durch
Verordnungen viele viele
Ausnahmeregelungen treffen kann diesen
Zustand braucht es eben nicht mehr und
dann finde ich ihn wichtig ein
Ausnahmezustand wo per Verordnung
regiert werden kann dann auch zu beenden
und ich bin bei Ihnen das ist eine
kommunikative Herausforderung aber ich
denke die schaffen wir gemeinsam
Dankeschön Herr Spahn für das Gespräch
gerne
das Interview haben wir aufgezeichnet
der Wall geht in der CDU das Ringen um
die künftigen Spitzenposten weiter
sollte Jens Spahn offiziell seinen Hut
in den Ring werfen könnte zum Kreis der
Konkurrenten auch Friedrich Merz gehören
der in Sachen Corona übrigens
nachdrücklich eine schnelle Rückkehr zur
Normalität gefordert hat da herrscht
also Einigkeit in der neuen Ampel
hingegen könnte es zu dem Thema noch
Diskussionen geben
apropos Ampel wird das die Zukunft sein
Dreier Bündnisse weil zwei Parteien
nicht mehr genug Stimmen
zusammenbekommen ist die Zeit der
Volksparteien die über 30 Prozent
einfahren vorbei der Frage ist torgebode
nachgegangen die CDU erhält 49 Prozent
wir bleiben die große Volkspartei
christlich-demokratische Union
Deutschlands weiterhin Kopf an
kopfrennen manche hat nur schon
abgeschrieben
Volksparteien ARD Bundestagswahl 2021
die SPD jubelt 25,7 Prozent auf der
anderen Seite Schock für die Union die
Wahl verloren mit 24,1 Prozent beide
Volksparteien vereinte Absturz auf weit
unter 30%. darf man sich da überhaupt
noch Volksparteien nennen darüber reden
zwei wie sie selbst sagen junge
Vertreter von Volksparteien
mein Name ist Sarah Beckhoff ich bin 27
Jahre alt und Kreisvorsitzende der
Jungen Union Dortmund mein Name ist
Jannik Hahn ich bin 35 Jahre alt und
Vorsitzender der SPD Berlin Mitte ich
glaube nicht dass man auf Volksparteien
an den Prozenten ablesen kann weil sich
das immer mehr annähert sondern ich
glaube das ist einmal wie viel
Mitglieder hat man und wer ist Mitglied
wie divers sind die welche sozialen
Hintergründe bringen die mit also ich
glaube man muss davon Abschied nehmen
das jetzt irgendeine Partei noch mal 40
Prozent plus irgendwie erreicht die
Zeiten ändern sich mit Jungpolitikerin
Sarah Beckhoff im Dortmunder Museum für
Arbeitswelten braucht es heutzutage
überhaupt noch Volksparteien ist der Zug
für das Konzept Volkspartei nicht schon
längst abgefahren eine Volkspartei hat
die Aufgabe die Gesellschaft
zusammenzuhalten und das ist keine
leichte Aufgabe ich glaube aber schon
momentan dass wir
in Deutschland sehen dass sich die
Gesellschaft auch leicht spalten lässt
in verschiedene Lager und die
Volkspartei muss diese Lager ernst
nehmen und auch versöhnen eine
Wählergruppe hat man vielleicht zu lange
aus dem Blick verloren so sehen es die
Jungpolitiker denn junge Menschen fanden
sich nicht unbedingt in den
Volksparteien wieder sie haben wenig
Sprache in der Politik weil weil wir
eine sehr stark Überalterung auch der
Systeme der ist Parlamentes sehen der
Bundesregierung auch und ich glaube dass
man die besonders in den Blick nehmen
muss und auch eine Sprache finden muss
wie man den Prozess einbeziehen kann ich
als junge Frau kann auch Politik machen
für meine Oma oder ja für meinen Vater
oder für meinen Bruder mit dem anderen
Schulabschluss solange ich weiß
wie die Interessen in der Gesellschaft
aussehen und wie sieht die Zukunft der
Volksparteien aus wird es Volksparteien
überhaupt noch geben
also in die glastruhe kann ich nicht
schauen ich würde mir sehr wünschen dass
die CDU wieder dahin kommt 40 Prozent
auch bundesweit zu erlangen ich glaube
die SPD muss den Anspruch Volkspartei
behalten aber mit einem klaren linken
Anspruch und dann glaube ich wird es
auch gut für die Zukunft politik
bedeutet immer dicke Bretter bohren und
einfach es ist glaube ich nicht die
wichtig ist halt nur dass man nicht
aufgibt und ich glaube an das Konzept
der Volksparteien
und jetzt macht Heinz Wolf weiter mit
den Nachrichten und dazu erst mit dem
Konflikt mit der Türkei ja nach der
angedrohten Ausweisung von zehn
Botschaftern aus der Türkei beraten die
betroffenen Staaten darunter auch
Deutschland und die USA über eine
angemessene Reaktion wie eine Antwort
aussehen könnte dazu der Vorsitzende des
Auswärtigen Ausschusses Röntgen
vielleicht kann man es noch abwenden
wenn nicht muss klar sein dass wenn
Erdogan sich entscheidet auf
Botschafterebene nicht mehr mit einer
Handvoll von europäischen Staaten und
den USA verkehren zu wollen dass das
dann die selbe Gegenreaktion von allen
Mitgliedstaaten der Europäischen Union
Erfolge haben muss
Anlass für den Eklat ist der Fall des in
der Türkei Inhaftierten Unternehmers und
kulturförderers Rossmann Kavala dessen
Botschafter gefordert hatten
Innenminister Seehofer will die
Kontrollen im deutsch-polnischen
Grenzgebiet falls nötig weiter
verstärken das sagte er der Bild am
Sonntag schon jetzt sind 800 schafften
der Bundespolizei zur Verstärkung vor
Ort um Migranten zu überprüfen die über
Belarus und Polen nach Deutschland
kommen in der Nacht griff die Polizei
auch rund 50 Rechtsextremisten auf die
patroullieren wollten dazu hatte eine
rechtsextreme Partei aufgerufen
vom Süden Mexikos aus haben sich mehr
als 2000 Migranten hauptsächlich aus
Mittelamerika auf den Weg Richtung USA
gemacht unter einer Brücke durchbrachen
sie eine Barriere der Sicherheitskräfte
und setzten anschließend ihren Weg fort
viele berichteten dass sie seit Monaten
auf die Bearbeitung Ihrer Asylanträge
warten mussten
in Kolumbien ist der meistgesuchte
Drogenboss des Landes dairo usaka alias
rotondiel verhaftet worden und 500
Einsatzkräfte waren an sogar Festnahme
in einem Waldgebiet beteiligt der Chef
des größten Drogenkartells des Landes
war zehn Jahre auf der Flucht auf jeden
Fall eine Belohnung von fast sechs
Millionen Dollar ausgesetzt Kolumbiens
Präsident dugen nannte es den bisher
schwersten Schlag gegen den Drogenhandel
in diesem Jahrhundert und verglichen
Pablo Escobar
die Tage im August als das Chaos in
Kabul ausbrach haben sich ins Gedächtnis
gebrannt die Bilder der Verzweiflung
Menschen die sich an ein Flugzeug
Klammern oder sich vor den Toren des
Flughafens drängen und nicht durchkommen
es waren unerträgliche Szenen und
Zeugnisse politischen Versagens denn
dass man vor dem Abzug der Amerikaner
wenigstens die afghanischen Bundeswehr
Mitarbeiter rausgeholt haben muss das
war über Wochen und Monate gefordert
worden allen voran von
Bundeswehrsoldaten denen das Schicksal
ihrer ehemaligen Mitarbeiter am Herzen
liegt
in den Tagen der Luftbrücke wurden von
der deutschen Luftwaffe rund 5.300
Menschen ausgeflogen nur wenige hundert
davon waren Bundeswehr ortskräfte wie
viele jetzt noch in Afghanistan
ausharren ist unklar was wird aus ihnen
Kathrin Eigendorf berichtet
es kommt selten vor dass Sultan masut
assimi mit seinen drei Kindern vor die
Türe geht meistens verbringen Sie den
ganzen Tag in der Wohnung die sie
provisorisch bezogen haben seitdem sie
aus Massai Sharif nach Kabul geflohen
sind ich habe Angst ich befürchte mich
dass sie jemanden erkennt mich also in
der Öffentlichkeit mein großes
Befürchtung ist dass das wegen meinen
Kindern wenn etwas mit mir passiert wir
wissen Sie schon den Leben von das Leben
gar nichts asimi hat sein ganzes Hab und
Gut verkauft nur die Ausweise und
Zeugnisse aus seiner Zeit bei der
Bundeswehr bewahrt er wie einen Schatz
acht Jahre lang von 2007 bis 2015 hat er
als sogenannter sprachvermittler
gearbeitet in der Hoffnung auf einen der
evakuierungsflüge zu gelangen flohen sie
wie so viele andere nach Kabul
auch sie kämpften im Gedränge des
Flughafens riskierten ihr Leben und
blieben schließlich zurück
einen Antrag auf ein Visum hat er
Familienvater gestellt die Antwort lies
der uns vor vielen Dank für Ihre
Nachricht
sobald Ihre Antrag bearbeitet ist werden
Sie weiter Informationen per SMS
telefonisch oder mein Herr halten mit
freundlichen Grüßen und
Bearbeitungsstelle ausgehefte für
Erfahrung der Bundeswehr
bis jetzt warten wir immer noch seitdem
die Taliban in Kabul die Macht
übernommen haben geht die Angst um vor
allem bei denen die für ausländische
Militärs gearbeitet haben doch es sind
auch die Zukunftsaussichten die sich
deutlich verschlechtert haben als
Lehrerin kann pawana nicht mehr arbeiten
auch die Kinder sind zu Hause
unsere wirtschaftliche Lage war gut mein
Mann hat gearbeitet meine Kinder sind
zur Schule gegangen sie hatten eine gute
Ausbildung und meine Kinder sind begabt
jetzt gehen sie nicht zur Schule wir
sitzen alle zu Hause auch ich habe eine
gute Ausbildung und nun keinen Job mehr
trotz Sorge um seine Sicherheit möchte
azimi sich offen vor der Kamera zeigen
er möchte dass seine Geschichte in
Deutschland gehört wird
wir wollen erwarten von der Dusche
Bundesregierung dass der
evakurierungsprozess ein bisschen zu
beschleunigen weil wirklich haben wir
Probleme also unsere Kinder gehen nicht
zur Schule also unsere Frauen Angst hat
Angst draußen zu gehen mit über 100
anderen ortskräften hat assimi eine
Gruppe gebildet sie wollen sich
gegenseitig informieren über neue
Entwicklungen bis dahin bleibt nur
warten
und jetzt noch mal Heinz mit Meldungen
vom Sport an diesem Wochenende zuerst
zur Fußball-Bundesliga da gab es heute
drei Spiele mit diesen Ergebnissen 1 fC
Köln Bayer Leverkusen 2:2 Stuttgart
Union Berlin 1 zu 1 Bochum Eintracht
Frankfurt 2:0
der VfL Wolfsburg trennt sich von
Trainer Mark van Bommel nach starkem
Saison Start blieb der VfL zuletzt acht
Pflichtspiele sieglos in der Bundesliga
steht Wolfsburg aktuell auf Platz 9
zum Abschluss der Bahnrad-WM in
Frankreich hat leer so viel Friedrich
heute ihre dritte Goldmedaille gewonnen
die 21-Jährige holte nach Gold im
Teamsprint und im 500 Meter Zeitfahren
auch noch im keilriemenwettbewerb den
WM-Titel insgesamt gab es für das
deutsche bahnradteam sechsmal Gold
zweimal Silber und dreimal Bronze
und bei der Kunstturnen WM in Japan hat
Pauline schäferbets Silber gewonnen nach
einer starken Kühe am Schwebebalken
machte die 24-Jährige in ihrem dritten
WM-Finale ihren Medaillensatz komplett
der Sieg ging an die Japanerin hurra
ashigawa ihre Teamkollegin maymuta
Carmen belegte den dritten Platz
der Friedenspreis des Deutschen
Buchhandels war immer ein
gesellschaftspolitisches Statement kein
Literaturpreis im engeren Sinne der
Friedenspreis will zur
Völkerverständigung beitragen und
sichern aktuellen Debatten beteiligen
das ist auch in diesem Jahr gelungen
angesichts des Streits wer auf der
Frankfurter Buchmesse ausstellen sollte
und wer nicht die diesjährige
Preisträgerin zieht sie danka remga ist
nicht nur Schriftstellerin sondern auch
Feministin politische Aktivistin und
eine herausragende Stimme Afrikas die
britische BBC setzte ihren ersten Roman
auf die Liste der 100 Bücher die die
Welt verändert haben allerdings erst 30
Jahre nachdem das Buch erschienen war
Vulkan untypisches Beispiel für die
jahrzehntelange Ignoranz gegenüber
Literatur aus der ehemaligen Kolonie
Sandra Zeiss und Peter Wagner stellen
uns die Preisträgerin vor
die Geschichte von
cici-dangaremgeist wie die des gesamten
afrikanischen Kontinents untrennbar mit
dem Kolonialismus verbunden als sie hier
1959 geboren wird heißt Simbabwe noch
Rhodesien eine Kolonie des britischen
Empire ihr Elternhaus ist später bei
einem Unfall abgebrannt
auf diesem Boden habe ich wohl meine
ersten Schritte gemacht
irgendwo hier war das Schlafzimmer
meiner Eltern das Kinderzimmer
das Wohnzimmer die Küche alles ist weg
ihr Vater ist Lehrer an einer
Missionsschule sie kommt in den Genuss
von Bildung studiert Psychologie mit 29
veröffentlicht sie den ersten Roman ihre
Trilogie um das Mädchen tambusai die
Figur erlebt Unterdrückung das
Patriarchat Rassismus Themen die auch
das Leben der Autorin prägen und ihren
friedlichen Kampf für Freiheit und
Gerechtigkeit
dafür bezieht sie dann der remga mit dem
Friedenspreis des Deutschen Buchhandels
ausgezeichnet als zwölfte Frau und der
bisher 72 Preisträger für sie hat die
ihn vielen postkolonialen Ländern
anzutreffen eine Gewalt einen Ursprung
diese Gewalt ist bei allen imperialen
Unternehmungen des westlichen Viertels
der Welt im Rest der Erde üblich ein
Prozess der im 15 Jahrhundert begann es
liegt auf der Hand das Frieden unter
diesen Bedingungen nicht gedeihen kann
deshalb spricht sich dankaremga für eine
neue Aufklärung aus für veränderte
Denkmuster
unsere Entscheidung was und wie wir
denken ist letztlich eine Entscheidung
zwischen Gewalt oder Frieden fördernden
Inhalten und narrativen
Obama die Halbschwester des ehemaligen
US-Präsidenten und zieht sie dann
garremga kennen sich seit gemeinsamen
Studienzeiten in Berlin ihre Laudatio
ist ebenso herzlich wie persönlich
manchmal am liebsten aufgegeben
der versuchen nachgegangen einfach ein
normales gewöhnliches Leben zu führen
warum sich mühsam gehören verschaffen
wenn man auch irgendwie so durch das
Leben kommen könnte
du bist nicht gewöhnlich CC
als Frankfurts UB fällt man einen
anderen Umgang mit rechten Verlagen auf
der Buchmesse fordert unterbricht die
grüne Stadtverordnete mahnen mit einem
engagierten Appell gegen dasismus wenn
wir dulden das rechtsradikale Menschen
mit genau diesen menschenverachtenden
Ideologien eine Plattform hier in
Frankfurt in meiner Stadt in unserer
Stadt in meiner Heimat bekommen dann
beteiligen wir uns aktiv an dem nächsten
Hanau es war eine außergewöhnliche
friedenspreisverleihung geprägt von drei
außergewöhnlichen Frauen
und jetzt noch wie immer am Sonntag
unser Ausblick auf die nächste Woche da
steht politisch einiges an laura barnick
hat die wichtigsten Termine
zusammengestellt
[Musik]
2018 übergab Frank Walter Steinmeier
Angela Merkel ihre letzte
Ernennungsurkunde zur Kanzlerin am
Dienstag wird er ihr die
Entlassungsurkunde überreichen zuvor
wird sich der Bundestag zum 20 Mal neu
konstituieren die SPD stellt Bärbel Bars
als neue Bundestagspräsidentin zur Wahl
am Mittwoch soll der CDU-Politiker
Hendrik wüst zum Ministerpräsidenten von
Nordrhein-Westfalen gewählt werden der
bisherige Verkehrsminister will Armin
Laschet als Landesvater ablösen im Mai
stehen dann in NRW Landtagswahlen an
am Samstag werden sich in Rom die
führenden Köpfe der 20 wichtigsten
Industrie- und Schwellenländer zu
Beratungen treffen neben Afghanistan und
der Klimakrise beraten die G20 auch über
die Pandemie wegen Corona haben die
Präsidenten von China und Russland ihre
Reise nach Rom abgesagt
nach dem Klimagipfel 2019 in Madrid
kommen ab Sonntag erstmals wieder
Politiker Umweltschützer und
Klimaforscher in Glasgow zusammen sie
versuchen Vereinbarungen auszuhandeln um
die Klimaziele von Paris umzusetzen dazu
gehört auch die Erderwärmung auf 1,5
Grad zu begrenzen
und noch der Ausblick auf das Wetter
morgen im Süden hält sich am Vormittag
teils noch länger Nebel im Nordwesten
kommen am Nachmittag Wolken mit etwas
Regen auf sonst scheint häufig die Sonne
die Temperatur steigt auf 10 bis 19 Grad
am Dienstag ist es oft trübe und es kann
im besten regnen ab Mittwoch bleibt es
wieder trocken und vor allem am
Donnerstag scheint auch verbreitet die
Sonne dazu gibt es 9 bis 16 Grad
das war es von uns hier übernehmen
morgen Bettina Schausten und Gundula
Gause
heute Express in eine gute Woche auf
Wiedersehen
[Musik]